you're adorable
all your jewelry and your shows you're
like a walking piece of art that's a
really good hug by the way i'm like i'm
like such a hugger he hates it but oh
i've heard but i don't know but if you
face me she does something else
[Laughter]
i will just not do that um so you that's
your first talk show right yeah cause
you're 19 right
wow
19 like i was just telling howie i was
like 19 and landing this amazing role
like are you just like pinching yourself
or feeling pressure or what are you
feeling it's a favorite dream
yeah floating constantly incredible yeah
so how long have you been acting
18 months going strong oh 10 months 18
months oh my god wow
when do you when do you stop counting
your career in months
when do people stop counting their like
newborn baby i don't know you know
you're from my hometown you're from
china markham markham yeah
well i grew up at bathurst and steel so
i that's where my family lives in
markham right i'm in unionville yeah i
know where you're from so i'm so proud
of you i'm so proud of this is a
hometown girl i love that it's so
refreshing to hear people actually
know markham because i keep saying
toronto which i needed so you're putting
it on the map i know markham ontario
markham
marvel markham to marvel
that's
amazing that is a great book in the
making so how did you find out about
miss marvel whatsapp
is that real yeah my aunt was part of
your life right now okay keep going it's
crazy my aunt was part of a group chat
that she never opens one day she decided
to and there was like the miss marvel
casting call and it was like a blank
page miss marvel sent hedgehog and
resumed this email super sketchy so
obviously i did it
but no i was a huge miss marvel fan in
high school i read all the comics i was
a marvel nerd my entire life surrounded
marvel and now people actually have to
listen when i talk about it because i
like work you get paid for it now it's
great it's amazing but um yeah it's
awesome though that you always loved it
and then you get your first role is like
something that you loved as a kid yeah
you're still a kid to me but you know i
was like i could be your mom
look we can how do you get a career
online it's like yeah that's amazing
your pants went online
yeah what's that and it was like this is
the brownest way this could have
happened like for south asians whatsapp
is our home
[Laughter]
it's costco and what's that
you're funny too
thank you very much
is it true that you gave marvel feedback
on like all the marvel movies i gotta be
honest everything that happened in my
first year at marvel was such a blur but
yeah i probably did i like every time i
see a new movie i'm like texting kevin
or victoria like hey so next time maybe
tried this instead but like you're on
the right track
oh my god they like can't say no to me
now did you leave school
no i got cast on the last day of high
school
what is your life perfect graduation
present considering i didn't get one
because of kovid so
yeah well there you did though we don't
feel real bad yeah no one feels bad for
you right now so wait one of the coolest
things though is you are marvel's first
muslim superhero that's like really cool
too just
that it's so cool does it feel because
the the inclusivity is awesome
do you feel pressure because of that
because you're like holding something
down like all by yourself right now
nope nope
i love you no i mean you know what's
great a catholic a muslim and a jew we
should go a walk into a bar
christian
well let's walk into a bar i know
something really funny right now that's
a great joke i love it it's coming can't
no but there's there's a lot of pressure
with being the first of anything i just
i don't think about it like i can't wake
up everyone and be like you're the first
muslim pakistani superhero do good okay
for your people
but uh like no it's just
the superhero part is so cool and it's
just like working with my idols and i'm
just there's so much inspiration and and
like representation for me behind the
camera like all the creatives on our
show have such a
emotional attachment to this character
into the story and they're bringing so
much of that and i think that's just why
i'm here i think it's awesome that you
are so chill about it too because i
think that's also
i feel like i came in the industry at 19
as well and it and everybody would say
oh do you feel pressure and it was so
funny i got that question i was like no
but sh
should i i was like i would freak out
because i i think people naturally want
to ask the question but sometimes i
think when you are 19 years old you're
just like i'm just like doing what i
love and it's like fun and i'm like
there's no like jade there's no reason
other than that which is kind of really
beautiful yeah i do this for free my dad
was like don't say that
i'm sure your agent said that too
i don't know
her life is so weird it's so wonderful i
know it's amazing you're like a dream
come true lady
yeah thank you your hometown girl is
killing it
[Music]